The system in Russia,
the Soviet Union,
which was a collection of states,
an empire,
and the system that was established in
China and the system that still exists
in Korea as a remnant of the Cold War
and systems in Southeast Asia and in
Africa were all predicated on Marxist
presuppositions,
presuppositions that were Utopian in
nature
and that
posited a utopian future where property
was held in common and everyone had
enough and everyone was called upon to
do what they could write from each
according to his ability to each
according to his need,
which is a lovely sentiment and you can
imagine how it would be attractive even
intellectually because of course other
systems,
all other systems produce vast
disparities in income.
It's like a natural law.
It's actually governed by.
You can model it
with a distribution called the prieto
distribution and the prieto
distribution.
It looks like this.
It doesn't look like a normal
distribution.
A lot of you guys have been told about
normal distributions and how many things
follow a normal distribution.
Most things,
but that's really a limited case.
You can understand that prieto
distribution,
if you.
You've all played monopoly,
I presume at the beginning.
Everyone has the same amount of money,
will include property,
the same amount of wealth and then what
happens as the game progresses and
really as a function of chance.
I mean I know yet you have to use your
head a little bit monopoly,
but the basic rule is just buy
everything you can get your hands on and
then trade meanly,
something like that.
So at the beginning everybody has the
same amount and then as you begin to
play,
if you had enough players,
you would develop an,
a normal distribution because some
people would win,
see relatively consistently and some
people would lose relatively
consistently.
And so the money starts to be
distributed in a normal distribution.
But the thing about money and the thing
about lots of things is that zero is
involved in zero is a weird place
because if you're playing a trading game
and you hit zero,
then you're done.
And so,
and it's very hard to recover from zero
and you know,
it's really hard to recover.
You know when you're doomed and
monopoly,
you know,
you can tell you've got some resources,
but there's gonna be some crisis when
you land on some hotel and you're going
to get wiped out,
you know it,
so there's a point at which you're
headed for zero.
Even if you have something you know and
you might be rescued by luck,
but you know when you're doomed.
So what happens is that as you continue
to play monopoly more and more people
stack up at zero and fewer and fewer
people have more and more money,
and when the game is over,
everyone has nothing except one person.
They have all of it.
Now,
the funny thing about that is that in
some sense that's how trading games
work.
You know,
you've got.
You might wonder why is that,
why there is any quality in this society
and it's easy to consider that it's
because the society is corrupt and
perhaps no society is ours somewhat or
horribly corrupt.
That's the variation.
There is no society that's without.
It's criminal and criminal element,
fixed element anyways.
Trading Games tend to produce a prieto
distribution so that very many people
have very little and a tiny minority
have a tremendous amount.
That's the one percent that you hear
about.
Right?
And you know the thing about that one
percent is that that's happened in every
society that's ever been studied.
It doesn't really matter what the
governmental system is and it certainly
handled.
It certainly happened under the Soviets,
that's for sure.
And there was a lot of people who had
enough zero so they just died.
So you know,
the,
the Utopian dream was completely
unimplementable for a variety of very
complex reasons.
One is that it's very hard to fight
against that distribution pattern when
people are trading because mirror
statistics will do that.
And then there's other things that,
and I should tell you as well that the
prieto distribution government governs a
lot of things.
So if you look at books,
if I remember properly last year there
was something like a million English
language books published and I think 500
of them sold more than 100,000
copies,
which is none,
right?
That's none of that 500,
you can be sure that one of them was by
Stephen King and he took half the money
because there's like five authors in the
English language who are on every
airport,
paperback stand,
occupying the top rung,
and that's massive real estate,
right?
Because it's replicated everywhere and
because they're so prominent and because
there are no names when people are in a
hurry and they just want something to
read,
they just grabbed that and then more
money goes to those people and so you
know,
success breeds success and failure
breeds failure and it's not necessarily
linear.
Now.
It's a really difficult thing to deal
with and it's hard on societies because
one of the things we do know is that,
you know,
as you stretch out the inequality,
you make men particularly on the lower
end of the distribution,
more and more likely to be aggressive.
It's sort of like imagine every man has
a threshold for violence and status is
important to men.
Not that it's not important to women,
but it's a different.
It's a different kind of status.
It's status is important to men because
it's one of the things that makes them
marketable as partners to women's what
actually turns out to be quite important
to men than men.
Men tend to compete with one another for
status,
hierarchy position and in a really
unequal society.
If you're like a low rung guy then and
you don't have any opportunity to rise
because the society isn't structured so
that there's mobility.
Then the more aggressive guys tend to
turn into criminality and you know,
and so you could say there's a threshold
for criminality and the more inequality
pressure you put on a particular area,
geographic or political area,
the more inequality pressure you put on
it,
the more men slip past that threshold
and into criminality.
And you know,
there's been pretty good studies done of
drug gang in Chicago.
That was the best one.
As sociologist actually went and hung
out with a drug gang for.
He got into it.
I guess the drug gang leader was.
No,
I wouldn't say necessarily narcissistic,
but that might be a reasonable way of
thinking about it and he was kinda happy
with the idea of maybe being a subject
of a book and and so this guy was able
to associate with them,
got to know them quite well.
And then the housing project in which
the gang was how housed was slated for
demolition and the gang broke up and he
got the books because the books and what
he found was the average street drug
dealer,
first of all was employed in another job
as well and was making far less than
minimum wage now.
But the guys further up the chain of
course followed the prieto distribution.
And so there was a tiny minority of them
who were raking in a tremendous amount
of loot.
And the guys at the bottom,
we're just waiting around for the
possibility that they could rise up the
hierarchy.
And you know,
it's pretty violent game.
So the chances that someone is going to
be
taken out is pretty high.
And then a little slot opens up for some
opportunistic second rater.
And perhaps he can move up the
hierarchy.
So the prieto distribution,
governance,
all sorts of other things too.
I mentioned it governs the popularity
books,
the sales of books,
but it also,
it also characterizes the distribution
of everything that people produce.
So if you think of creative production
of any sort,
artistic production,
industrial production,
it doesn't matter.
Almost everything fails
and a few things succeed beyond anyone's
wildest imagination.
Apple's a good example of that.
No,
I mean the iphone,
they have their competitors,
but is it extraordinarily dominant
product and they rake in billions of
dollars,
I think.
I don't know if apple is valued at a
trillion dollars,
but it's close to that.
And that's a lot of money.
And I think if I remember correctly,
it's something like this,
I probably have the figures wrong,
but like the top 40 people,
the richest 40 people in the world have
as much money as the bottom 2 billion
right now.
You know,
it's not like they're stuffing their
mattresses with that money or they have
a skyscraper full of cash.
That money is out in the economy doing
whatever money does.
So you know,
you can't spend $28,
billion dollars,
so and sometimes you can even do some
good with it.
You know,
Bill Gates seems to be doing something
reasonable with his money.
But the reason I'm telling you this is
because one of the things you should
know is that this proclivity for
inequality is pervasive among the
creative products of human beings.
It's the case with with goals scored in
hockey.
My son told me,
and he's a reliable source on hockey
statistics that
if Wayne Gretzky,
if you don't count any of the points
that Wayne Gretzky managed with scoring,
he still had enough points just with
assists to have more points than any
hockey player that ever played.
So you know,
you even at the upper end of,
of,
of the distribution or some person who's
hot,
they're so good at what they do.
And then there's another person that's
so much better than them that it's not
even comparable.
And so.
And the benefits flow to people who are
in that position.
And you can understand why I would say.
Because now let's say you start writing
and you get a book and a rare thing,
very rare things to have happened and
then some people read it and they like
it,
and then of course it's much more likely
that you'll get a next book.
And if people like that,
well it's even more likely that you'll
get a third book and then people start
to know who you are and then because
they know who you are,
they phone you up and offer you
opportunities and your network grows and
it's like this exponential increase in
your reach and your capacity for
production and more and more flows to
you.